[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pegman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
[Music]
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
big massive dumpster
[Music]
okay all right guys um you can be damn
sure
that when vladimir putin invades ukraine
he will allow no
low flow toilets those are for [ __ ]
boys and bettas they are going to be all
power flushers that you can be sure of
putin would not have any less than that
we are standing by for a very important
press briefing from white house press
secretary jen saki which we'll start
shortly if you need to be brought up to
speed as the case may be on what's going
on with the russian invasion of ukraine
i don't want to kind of like reset
everything from the top
but we just published this clip and you
can tell from the from the gesture i'm
making in the video that it's like a
really engaging video
and i basically bring you up to speed to
now and if you watch this at 1.5 x it'll
only take you about seven minutes and
then you will be fully caught up on
what's going on the clip is called
breaking russia invades ukraine and you
can see this on our youtube channel
right now but we are now standing by
for a white house press briefing i
imagine the vast majority of the
questions will be about the situation in
russia and ukraine uh jensaki will be
joined by the deputy national security
advisor and that is starting momentarily
so it's great to have everybody back
standing by standing back and standing
forward and all of these different
things we have an incredibly powerful
super chat from joseph dinzies
who says
hey david love from ukraine i have come
over from israel to support ukrainian
independence from russian imperialism
good to see you were not a part of the
tanky left who have been on the side of
russia wish me well thanks wow
about
four or five different layers of drama
just in that one super chat there's a
lot happening there be safe joseph uh
hope you're well jd straight shot says
what will war with russia do to the
price of mangoes art uncharged pickles
and trump's re-election prospects
i assume everything will go up in price
and quickly quit very very very very
quickly
um okay
let's get right into things
thanks to jen here
and merkellist as well as oscar
owns
and
aj4a
that's one two three four five
kicking us off over on twitch
we have uh a lot is happening today it's
hard to even keep track of everything
that's happening and remember we do have
the coupon code on our website please
don't war please don't war
um which you can use to sign up with a
discount okay let's go right into a
bunch of different things that i have
first this is a brief departure just as
it's kind of a for the lulz moment
yesterday
kyle rittenhouse famous only for killing
a few people i mean quite literally
that's the only thing
that he is um
that he is known for
and providing medico
he has launched an organization called
the media accountability project which i
guess will sue media outlets
look at this clip it's perfect he
doesn't even know what they're gonna do
he starts chugging water and at one
point looks off to the side
you couldn't this if this were a skit it
would be indistinguishable look at this
for kyle thanks so much for coming on
tonight i don't i can't think of many
people who've been at the receiving end
of this much sinister lying from
so-called news organizations as you have
how are you going to respond yeah
well tucker thank you for having me um
of course me and my team have decided to
by the way he has a team now that's
i'd love to meet who's on the team
something tells me like he they don't
exactly have phil jackson as equivalent
as the coach you know launched the media
accountability project as a tool to help
fundraise and hold the media accountable
for the lies they said and deal with
them in court
interesting so the idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
right
the water chug and the look to the side
is is just unbelievably perfect so the
idea is
maybe like the covington catholic kids
you will be suing news organizations
that maliciously lie about people who
are in the news
is that the plan
yes sir we're gonna be holding them
accountable tucker
[Music]
tucker's as confused as kyle it's not
clear that either of them know what
they're gonna be doing with tmap
do you
[Laughter]
someone's gotta be taking advantage of
this kid right like i mean he doesn't
have any idea what they're doing he just
has no clue whatsoever what it is that
they they've launched
um but they're certainly going to be
holding the media accountable thanks to
steven circ who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code obama
obama you were new member number six
today i really appreciate that i also
want to say thanks to nzn8
for the twitch prime subscription
uh you are number seven today and i
really appreciate that as well
i appreciate everybody i appreciate
everybody more super chats coming in
shecklesmack says only obama
patrick reilly says you can't get mini
dills in massachusetts never mind your
bag of mango mini mini dill pickles
i don't know growing up in massachusetts
we had no shortage of dills that's for
sure
oh also thanks to ireman for gifting
somebody a sub over on twitch i really
do appreciate that
okay let's continue as we stand by here
here is just a brief
sampling
of what people in florida who favor the
don't say gay bill are saying
i in all seriousness
maybe don't let kids see this okay
here's a sampling of some of the defiant
and principled
support
for the don't say gay bill
children in kindergarten do not need to
hear about a hundred different sexual
orientations sexual preferences in
reality and gender identities
our children are not and should not oh
god she had to be from boston
dear god what is she doing down in
florida gender identities
our children are not and should not be
part of a social experiment
this can only be known as indoctrination
should teachers tell children pick a
gender any gender you'll be happy do we
say lie cheat kill still he'll be happy
n-l-b-g-q
t-ish n-l-b-g-q
you guys be careful there okay that's
nlbgq
juice children can be traumatized by an
lbg can be happy or
nlbgqt issues children can be nlbgqt
n l b g cute i need is that that's got
to be some kind of wordle mass like
quadruple word score n
what what are the letters again hey
happy n l b g q
t h n l children can be traumatized by
non-biblical issues
i can tell you what's inappropriate is a
man and a speedo talking about sex to
class
and we will ban men or drag queen coming
into an elementary school oh my god so
anyway those are some of the people who
want the don't say gay bill
the and they are very now did she was
she in favor or against nlbgqt
dear god
uh and she was reading right that's
that's what's even crazier she read that
you should have a coupon code coupon all
right maybe
um
we'll look into that i want to say
thanks to veronica sigco who just signed
up on my website with the code please
don't war
aiden strange just signed up with the
coupon code wow 22
and leah sutton just signed up with the
code please don't war
at joinpackman.com also want to say
thank you to weslow
and
for the twitch prime subscriptions today
numbers 12 and 13. okay i did mention
that yesterday we had to drop the ban
on dozens it quite literally dozens of
people who were just in an incredibly
weaponized way
trolling our
uh live stream
a lot of pro-putin people just going
absolutely crazy some of them have asked
to be unbanned and i'm going to
adjudicate those unbans right now
user contender number
showed up yesterday
and said
it's sad to see how some weak men have
love for strong man putin okay that's a
good comment that's fair
then said erdogan loves feet
it's a little weird we are all going to
die run
wake up joe
if woman for many sex before end of
world wow that is that's like one of
those you know those articles written
like like celebrity net worth articles
there's some written about me and and
it's like they're barely coherent it's
like
is david pakman of gay
uh if woman for many sex before end of
world they were banned
and then their unbanned request was hard
to find something more pathetic than
being a twitch moderator i guess that's
a perma-ban
uh i would have probably unbanned them
except their unban request was toxic
user hello people
showed up yesterday and said in all caps
i know you're gonna bane demi
but uphold the people's republic of
donetsk and lagansk
u.s imperialism taking ells as well as
nazi friends pacman fu and f nazi nato
they were banned
their unban request is uphold the
people's republic of donetsk and lugansk
u.s imperialism okay david pakman you
libtard cuck that's going to be a
perma-ban
okay by the way if you're wondering why
this is broken it's from so many people
that i've banned it literally every time
it just pieces of it are crumbling off
like a brittle egg
uh user american nacho showed up and did
all caps let's go brandon that's not
allowed so they were banned
and then um their unban request is
really you're really falling off bro i'm
a right winger but i used to like your
moderate takes um my takes were never
moderate i don't know what year you're
referring to and uh let's go brandon is
not allowed
you're gone
that was weird that was a very strange
noise on that last one
and lastly
user raving mage says joe is so
incompetent he's failing on covid
maybe if mark milley was studying
something other than white rage he would
have been able to stop this historic
failure from biden biden is such a
failure so this person was really mostly
banned because they were rapid firing
messages
then said i broke no rules please unban
i will unban them it was mostly just to
give him a timeout okay here we go
there we go
um
so that's okay i'll allow them back
and uh
okay we did that and then thanks to jt
dagnino and a danish joint for the
twitch prime subscriptions numbers 14
and 15. we are standing by for a press
briefing from jensaki and the deputy
national security advisor dileep singh
any moment now they are expected there
is an invasion of ukraine happening
right now
many
uh what we might call revolutionary
leftists have apologized saying they
were wrong to write off putin's
uh threats and massing of a hundred and
ninety thousand troops at the ukrainian
border
uh they've said you know no it was
aggression it was aggression
tony says hello from bilisi georgia
david sending a super chat as a thank
you for being one of the few reasonable
youtubers it was disheartening to see a
lot of american left wing victim blame
and side with russia in the last few
weeks yes it is weird
yl says i'm ukrainian from nipro
and i think putin is a dictator and the
aggressor but i do feel sympathy for
people who don't want to be part of this
country sure
sure
uh
okay
let's continue with some other things
okay so we did this
uh oh oh oh oh
so trump gave uh i'm not gonna cop so
we've been calling them febrile screeds
lately
we need to we need a different term i
don't want to call trump's declarations
febrile screeds anymore what else might
we be able to call them any any ideas
maybe uh
weaponized rants i don't i don't really
know anyway trump is very impressed with
vladimir putin's smart invasion of
ukraine
um let's see
let me see if i can find it in the
transcript okay check this out
oh it's right at the oh is it at the
beginning no it's not let's see if we
can find the piece of it
the millions of people not two million
or one million like they say i say 10
million let's see where
the people are bum rushing
our country and many of these people
come from prisons okay here we go
this is gonna be there's 127 countries
now they have
but many of these countries are emptying
their prisons like we're dumping ground
right into our country
uh i've never seen anything like it i've
i don't think our country has ever been
so low you could take the five worst
presidents in the history of our country
and put them together i don't think
they've done the damage that this
administration has done so here we go in
the last 24 hours we know russia has
said that they are recognizing two
breakaway regions of ukraine and now
this white house is stating that this is
an invasion
that's a strong word what went wrong
here what has the current
occupant of the oval office done that he
could have done differently
well what went wrong was a rigged
election
went wrong as a candidate that shouldn't
be there and a man that has no concept
of what he's doing i went in yesterday
and there was a television screen and i
said this is genius
putin
declares
a big portion
of the ukraine of ukraine putin declares
it as independent oh that's wonderful so
putin
is now saying it's independent a large
section of ukraine
i said how smart is that and he's going
to go in and be a peacekeeper that's the
strongest peace for us we could use that
on our southern border that's the
strongest peace force i've ever seen
there were more army tanks that i've
ever seen they're going to keep peace
all right no but think of it here's a
guy who's very savvy i know him very
well very very well by the way this
never would have happened with us guys
he's super impressed he's so impressed
with putin now i understand that some
people are saying it sort of
sounds like sarcasm he's being sarcastic
about the idea that it's a peacekeeping
force trump recognizes it's not a
peacekeeping force but what's funny is
he
they're sort of being critical of the
fact that it's being called an invasion
but he's recognizing that it is an
invasion but he's clearly smitten with
putin it's it's unbelievable
unbelievable he says we need russian
tanks on our border to stop mexicans
from getting in
it's stunning
stunning
um and it there's there's tons of this
stuff so we're going to look at this
very very closely tomorrow uh we're
monitoring what's going on in in ukraine
now
as many of you i'm sure would agree with
me
whenever there's a geopolitical conflict
whenever things get complicated
difficult when i need moral clarity and
strength of character and decisiveness i
immediately think
what is tulsi gabbard thinking about
this issue that's immediately where my
mind goes
and she
had the following to say to sean hannity
standing the world that we live in and
not the world that maybe some people
wished existed and that reality is putin
has made very clear all along
that uh their security and his mind uh
is what's at stake here and they do not
want to interrupt us putin also said
ukraine is not a country
and he has been saying this going back
many many years so this has been these
territorial ambitions have existed
when sean hannity
weaponized
delusional nuclear
propagandist goes tulsi
you might be going a little too far with
the putin apologia you know you've gone
off the rails
you're completely off the off the rails
when hannity's like i would pump the
brakes a little tulsi on some of this
russian propaganda uh unbelievable and
remember this
this is the last real liberal guys
she's she's a true liberal because she's
against wars
supposedly
um
unbelievable stuff this is on my podcast
today as well
uh so definitely definitely check that
out
um the markets reacting uh
not surprisingly
very negatively to what's going on down
another 1.4 percent um basically this
means i'm gonna have to work an extra
two years this th this is the this war
is delaying my retirement by two years
now okay i mean obviously as many of you
know i i hold stocks and bonds like like
many people and i don't touch them i
don't trade i'm not doing anything i'm
just waiting um but but by the way
if you do want my market insights i will
be publishing some of them to my tick
tocks
some of you might know we are
approaching 75 000 tick tocks followers
and we're get i will be answering
finance questions including should i
sell everything
hint the answer is no
over on my tick tocks which is uh very
very quickly going crazy you might have
seen where was it
um i did one recording it was extremely
windy
as you can see
and sometimes it no matter how windy it
is i still record my tick tocks so
that's just something to think about and
something to be aware of
in case you like different types of
content okay
so that's that
so we can close this out
um
blinken says
blinken and ukrainian foreign minister
briefing reporter hold on this isn't
this is our third fourth encounter in
the last four days
and this speaks for the dynamics and the
quality of our relationship but also for
the
urgency of the
current crisis that needs to be handled
right
we meet at a very tense and responsible
time for ukraine for the united states
and for the world
we all are at a critical juncture for
the security of europe
as well as international my guess is
saki's waiting for this to finish so
let's watch we'll keep an eye russian
aggression has brought the world to the
edge of the largest catastrophe since
world war ii
yesterday president putin moved to
recognize two pieces of ukrainian land
as independent entities
ukraine does not and will never
recognize this absurdity
neither will the world recognize it in
fact what putin recognized is not the
so-called donisk people republican
ludang people republic
he recognized his direct responsibility
for the war against ukraine
and unprovoked and unjustified war on
another sovereign state in europe
which russia now intensifies
president putin killed minsk agreements
and more broadly he
attacked the world order
needless to say
russia's move is a grave breach of
international law and a new act of
aggression against ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity
therefore ukraine strongly believes that
the time for sanctions is now
and in this context we welcome today's
announcement of sanctions by president
biden
the world must respond with all its
economic might to punish russia for the
crimes it has already committed
and ahead of the crimes it plans to
commit
hit
russia's economy
now
and hit it hard
i commend immense efforts of the us
diplomacy led by tony to mobilize the
global coalition of allies and partners
to stop russia
the entire world stands today with
ukraine and rightly so
putin wants much more than a war-torn
piece of ukrainian land and people
living there
what stops him
is only our unity and resolve
and we can still
stop him
ukraine continues the engagement with
the united states eu and nato in
diplomatic efforts to ease tensions
yet
we also stand ready
for any possible development
we had a focused discussion today with
secretary blinken on steps to protect
ukraine and our multi-dimensional
resilience
one of the proposal that we put forward
today
is designing a program similar to the
land lease
implemented during the world war ii to
support
the war efforts of the allies in eastern
in is in in europe
this program will help to ensure
sustainable sustainability
and will improve efficiency
in
the uh in strengthening the capacity of
ukraine to defend itself
the last
point that i would like to make uh today
we discussed some very specific ideas
and i appreciate we appreciate very
concrete steps made by the united states
these days we receive
proposals
from some countries to condemn
russia's behavior
to condemn but not follow the
condemnation with action
and i would like to say that
condemnations are important
but it's
actions that really matter now these
days
and i'm grateful to our strategic
partner the united states
for its ironclad support
including military
economic
and
political diplomatic assistance provided
to ukraine
the ukrainian people will surely
remember the united states standing with
ukraine
at this decisive moment in history thank
you
we'll now turn to questions and we'll
take two from each delegation uh we'll
start with vivian salama of the wall
street journal
thank you very much
um
mr secretary president biden said three
days ago that if russia invades
they will have chosen war and the door
to diplomacy will be closed today
however he seemed to have left the door
open for diplomacy despite labeling what
russia has done as an invasion and so
even though you've now cancelled your
meeting with uh minister lavrov can you
say what the circumstances would entail
to justify
talks at this point absent say a full
withdrawal good question does the
actions in dunbas kind of open the door
for
potential negotiations and on that point
if you would both indulge me with two
questions um president putin today also
said that the crisis could be resolved
if kiev promised to abandon future
efforts to join nato and so that's been
a non-starter for the west so what
needs to happen then for any of these
talks to actually be entertained
um
mr kaleba good to see you again
uh question quick questions for you um
does the ukrainian government have any
plans to evacuate mariopol or kharkiv
in in the coming days just given that
the events that we've seen in donbass
and uh secondly the united states has
informed the united nations of
incredible of credible information
showing that moscow has compiled the
list of ukrainians to be killed or sent
to camps following a military occupation
were you informed of this list your
government was it informed of this list
and have any actions been taken to
respond to it thank you
thank you
i'm happy to start uh
first um
the
further
renewed russian uh invasion of ukraine
that has now begun
um
means uh clearly that the the the idea
of having a meeting this week
with foreign minister lavrov to pursue
diplomacy diplomacy now rejected
uh by russia uh does not make sense
but
having said that
to the extent there is anything that we
can do to avert uh an even worst-case
scenario an all-out assault on all of
ukraine including its capital
uh that would inflict horrific costs on
uh the ukrainian people uh we will
always uh pursue that so
we our partners uh remain open to
diplomacy but moscow needs to
demonstrate that it's serious
the last 24 hours has demonstrated just
the opposite
um it hasn't been serious to date
including with regard to the meeting
that was planned for thursday we made
clear
that in the context of a russian
invasion
we would not go forward with that
meeting if moscow's approach changes
we remain i remain very much prepared to
engage
um with regard to
president putin's statement about
nato and
the open door
it's very clear what we've seen uh in
the last 24 hours
that uh this has never been about
uh ukraine and nato per se
uh what president putin has made clear
is that this is about
the total subjugation of of ukraine
to russia
uh it's about reconstituting
uh the russian empire or short of that a
sphere of influence
or short of that
the total neutrality of countries
surrounding
russia
and so
the issue of
ukraine and nato has really been
an argument and excuse
to
mask the fact that what this is about is
president putin's view that ukraine is
not a sovereign country
that it does not have an existence or
independence
not associated in some fashion with
russia
a proposition that we not only firmly
reject but so does virtually every
ukrainian
i can only reiterate
uh
what
secretary just said on nato
nato is a choice of the people of
ukraine
no one but
ukraine and nato will decide on the
future of our
relationship and
it has never been about nato for putin
put it just an excuse even if even if we
do nothing
president putin will find a reason to
accuse us of doing something
regarding our plans to evacuate mario
paulioharkif
no we do not have such plans we have two
plans
plan a
is to
utilize
every tool of diplomacy
to deter russia and prevent further
escalation
and if that fails plan b
is to fight
for every inch of our land and every
city and every village
the
uh
to fight until we win of course
and about the list of extermination uh
no we haven't received it uh officially
[Music]
but i wouldn't exclude that such a list
can exist
we'll turn to olga koscielnko from
oneplus one media
good afternoon mr secretary of state uh
from your perspective is budapest
memorandum rather alive or dead
and do the united states recognize any
legal obligations under it and quick
follow up to mr coleba
what actions do you expect from partners
to be taken under budapest thank you
good question
well
in effect uh
russia began to tear up the budapest
memorandum in 2014
when it seized crimea and went into the
donbass uh
leading uh backing financing
supporting uh the separatists and waging
war in the donbass i think what we've
seen in the last
24 hours
is
the further
repudiation of budapest by russia
for our part
uh we have worked very hard over many
years and especially over the last year
to do everything we can to support
ukraine to support its territorial
integrity its sovereignty its
independence
through security assistance uh in the
last year alone more than in any
previous year
uh humanitarian assistance financial
assistance um
just uh about 10 days ago we provided an
additional loan guarantee of a billion
dollars to ukraine and of course
leading uh the effort internationally
to build support for ukraine in
this hour of need so we stand very much
behind
uh that that support support expressed
in the budapest memorandum and doing
everything that we can
to uphold ukraine's independence uh its
security its well-being
budapest memorandum is not a collective
defense treaty
so the truth is that never
no one promised us they would fight for
us if we are attacked this is not the
subject matter of the budapest
memorandum
but this document was concluded
uh on the premise
that
first
countries who provided
security assurances to ukraine
will themselves not use force against us
and second if that happens
they will do their utmost to stop it
so this is exactly the
should be the subject of the com of the
consultations that ukraine has initiated
recently
countries who
uh
belong to this legal and political field
space created by the budapest memorandum
have to come together
and
reach an agreement
on which specific action can
they take to uh protect ukraine
we understand that one of the
signatories of the budapest memorandum
is russia right who as secretary blinken
rightly said
violated all possible
international documents and agreements
but this does not wave other countries
of their responsibilities
to do their best
in order to help ukraine ukraine is a
country that exists in a security vacuum
this is true
our security guarantees our ukrainian
army and ukrainian diplomacy
but
we realize that but we do believe
that the decisions taken in 1994
when the memorandum was budapest
memorandum was concluded
they should be respected
because we sacrificed a lot
to
um
to make a long story short
we did a lot to strengthen global
security by abandoning our nuclear
arsenal
that was a huge contribution
and we expect on the principle of
reciprocity an equally huge contribution
to ensuring ukraine's security
ben hall fox news
thank you
thank you very much both uh this today
um foreign minister
there is a suggestion that what we've
seen so far is a minor invasion that
there's more to come and so it only
warrants
sort of lesser u.s sanctions i wonder if
that is your read as well and also you
and president zielenski called for tough
sanctions to be placed on russia before
the invasion you said this would happen
if not it has happened are you happy
with that in mind with the way the u.s
has handled this what more would you
like to see from the u.s and from the
international community to try and deter
more aggression
and
secretary blanken thank you
given that russia has invaded ukraine
regardless of all the threats of harsh
sanctions
the attempts at diplomacy what makes you
think that continuing down the same path
is going to deter them any further do
you think it's time to change tact do
you think diplomacy has failed
and secondly have you underestimated
putin
first there is no such thing as minor
middle or uh major invasion right
is an invasion beautiful
second as i said uh earlier
we do appreciate
today's the sanctions which were
announced today they target russia
they're very specific they are painful
i can say frankly that yesterday when we
learned about the first executive order
to impose sanctions on act related to
economic activities in the donetsk
with donetsk and lugansk
we were puzzled
because we saw
how the site that
thought recognition from russia is being
punished right but we didn't see how
russia who granted this recognition is
our analysis yes we saw it today right
and this strategy of
uh imposing sanctions by waves if i may
put it this way
is something that
that can work
if
it continues in a very sustained in a
sustainable way president putin should
not have a single minute
when
he starts to think
that this is the threshold this is the
the seal the the pressure reached its
ceiling and he will not be punished
anymore
this pressure should continue to be
stepped up
and
if that involves regular issuance of
executive orders on new sanctions we
will be more than happy to see to see
that
i will repeat again
we
can they seriously in a concerted effort
froze all oligarch assets in the u.s and
europe do you know how quickly these
corrupt dudes who got rich thanks to
putin would go to putin and say you
gotta cut this crap right away right
away and keep
mounting pressure on him
the question is that he has a certain
table in his mind which i'm not aware of
but i'm sure he has it
and we should also understand that
every next decision
should be taken in a swift action and we
saw two executive orders issued by the
president by president biden within what
less than 24 hours
this
may be the dynamics that will have to be
upheld
if
russia
continues to escalate and it was
encouraging to hear from secretary
a very simple sentence if russia
escalates the united states and partners
will escalate sanctions this is exactly
the rule that has to be followed
and yes we did believe
that
it would be helpful
for
some of sanctions not all of sanctions
but some of sanctions to be imposed
before
the invasion begins as a preemptive
measure
for what russia had done before
but this question becomes obsolete now
and
we have to focus on a different strategy
the one that i just described
um
then it's hard for me to improve much on
my friend dimitro's answer i'll just add
a couple of things
first
all along we said that we were pursuing
two tracks uh the track of diplomacy and
dialogue
uh to try to uh persuade
russia not to engage in a lot of
anti-semitism in the chat people getting
very very strongly banned and quickly
good job moderators
building up defense and building uh a
response i like is the anti-semitism
against me or against blinking uh it's
not even really clear i guess both
diplomacy and dialogue and instead to
pursue aggression
as a consequence
we have uh started to pursue
uh the severe consequences that we've
made clear would follow from any renewed
russian aggression
today
faced with the beginning of russia's
invasion of ukraine we started high and
we'll stay high
the sanctions that we've already
announced
go well beyond what we did in in 2014
full blocking sanctions against two of
russia's largest financial institutions
veb and the military bank
these institutions hold more than 80
billion dollars in assets they provide
key services that are critical
to financing uh the kremlin and russian
military
we have comprehensive sanctions against
russian sovereign debt what that means
is that we're cutting off the russian
government from western financing
sanctions on elites and family members
uh and
as promised as we've said all along
germany taking action
on nordstrom 2. and to repeat what
dimitro just emphasized
we've also made clear we're making clear
today
that if russia continues to escalate
so will we
and of course it's not only the
sanctions and other measures
of that that nature that are being taken
it is as we've made clear the
reinforcement of nato and its eastern
flank and continuing to provide and
indeed increase the support that we're
providing to ukraine against every
dimension
security
diplomatic political economic
humanitarian all of that
is in the mix
ultimately
president putin
by the way for people wondering it's
very clear that they've delayed the
press briefing until this one is done so
we shouldn't miss anything but
as i've said all along whatever his
decisions
we're prepared either way and we've
demonstrated that again today in full
coordination with allies and partners
oh i think to the contrary
um we've not underestimated him we've
actually laid out for the world
his entire playbook a playbook that he
is now following
and is making a video
yeah does rt still exist in english like
what are they i haven't even come across
anything from rt in years are they doing
putin apologia or like what's going on
on our team all along
we'll take a final question from dimitro
anapchenko from intro tv
mr blinken um i'm interested in your
opinion about normandy format
after all what happened in ukraine last
night i may one tell that it will not
work anymore and should be replaced like
ukraine proposed and secondly i got a
question which may sound very naive but
it's a question of
my audience in ukraine millions of
people who are really scared and if any
one of them will be on my place they
will ask you if russian troops will move
forward or if they will start uh intense
artillery fire hitting
ukrainian territory uh on your
understanding what will happen next and
what will america do
thank you
um
with regard to the uh the normandy
format i think the the question is best
directed at uh president putin right
as
far as we can see by the actions that
he's taken
uh he's rejected it uh and he's torn up
in effect the minsky agreements which
the normandy format was designed
uh to advance
so if uh russia is at all serious about
resolving
uh the conflict that it created
uh in the donbass pursuant to the
agreements it's it's signed the ministry
okay in in the chat let me know does
this entire thing last more than three
weeks or less than three weeks the uh
the normandy format all along with
france germany ukraine
and russia uh
working to implement the agreements and
throughout looking good
ukraine has worked very hard to make
good on its commitments
russia has done just the opposite but
what we've seen now in the last
24 hours would seem to be
the final repudiation
of uh of minsk by russia
but again you would have to ask
president putin
with regard to to what comes next as i
said a moment ago
and as we've said all along
will there be a pro-putin pro-russia
portion of cpac coming up this week
it will face the massive consequences
that not only the united states but
virtually all of our allies and partners
have made clear
would follow
you've heard this from the g7 the
leading democratic economies in the
world you've heard it from the european
union uh you've heard it from nato and
that includes
uh what we've started with today and
that is very severe economic and
financial sanctions that will exact
uh significant costs from russia
it includes
a reinforcement of nato
and
the defense of all allies
in nato and
it includes uh additional assistance to
ukraine uh in every area security
uh diplomatic uh political
economic humanitarian
all of that will follow and again i
repeat what i've said uh before if uh if
and as russia escalates so will we
thank you mr secretary thank you mr
minister
okay thank you everyone
so that is the end of a briefing
involving
anthony blinken
and the ukrainian foreign minister who
is strongly masked very very strongly
masked
and we are now standing by
for jensaki and the deputy national
security advisor they are going to take
many questions any minute now
and uh i think that there's going to be
a lot of interesting things taking place
there if you're just joining us welcome
we're continuing coverage of the
technically you know it's
slow
small
limited
very polite
invasion of ukraine by russia which
started yesterday
um
i want to say thank you to sir spam
assam the teal appeal
donatello
scientific
and hippie chick for the twitch prime
subscriptions i really appreciate that i
want to remind you guys
i once read
on an internet a report which said
um by the way guys that was a joke
people saying i'm down down playing the
invasion that was sarcasm guys
that was sarcasm
oh my god i can't even i can't even joke
on this show
um i've read that 90 percent of twitch
viewers have amazon prime
and only 10 percent use their free
twitch prime subscription okay
if that's true
if that's true
that means 800 people currently watching
on twitch
could subscribe for free with twitch
prime right now
and take some bezos bucks away from
bezos and send them to us
that's what i've been told
okay so this would be a great day for
that
i also want to say thank you to david
casey
and the great jared nedifie who have
signed up on my website
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
obama
you can also use the coupon code
please don't war please don't war we
don't want that
um
oh wow oh thanks to kaiser foo
hoz al
and charlie 301
for the twitch prime subscriptions i
really appreciate that mikko from
finland if i recall correctly says
please consider english-speaking
correspondent from ukraine on your show
would love that would love that by the
way i have three announcements of
programming notes to make for everybody
programming note number one i will be
live live live with cpac starting
thursday evening
uh we are expecting to hear from great
conservative speakers it is after all
the conservative political action
conference we are going to hear from
such conservative luminaries as
tulsi
don jr
don senior
and other conservative luminaries at
cpac we will be live with that starting
on thursday night
monday i will deliver the state of the
david pakman show address
and of course that is because on tuesday
a week from today joe biden will deliver
his state of the union we will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook with
biden state of the union
one week from today we will start about
an hour before
um so a ton of live content coming up
and last but not least
this is this is really what is this this
i see that it's very strange i i
apologize for that
it's a very strange
i don't know what that is
there we go that's better
um yeah
we will then be uh
have this is this is incredible
the truckers are planning a convoy from
i guess california to dc this weekend to
protest non-existent mandates
we are going to have an embedded
correspondent with the truckers guys
with the truckers
your support funds all of that stuff
okay
so that is uh that is going to be
something wild something wild and thank
you to m nelson the mike lennon giver of
life congawanga big fat pat
catoer tito
soul knife gambling gargoyle michael c
stone danish scent
celt flatulence that's clever scroot
scamander
whoa
wow all of whom just signed up via
twitch prime putting us at 34. i
appreciate that that that shutter s
startled me
that was crazy
uh a lot of content coming yes
absolutely so let's just run through a
couple other things uh stocks very very
hard down as we would say
charlie kirk is blaming
uh charlie kirk hold on what's happening
charlie kirk says basically putin is
just going places where he's welcome why
does putin feel so empowered the entire
western world is putting sanctions right
now on russia as they call this an
invasion farewell might be i'm not the
i'm not the person to determine whether
that is an invasion or an annexation it
feels as if putin is going into places
that want him yeah guys putin's going
places where they're welcoming him
i mean come on
what's the big deal here
uh
that's a hot take from charlie kirk
really really something else
um other super chats coming in david
this doesn't mean to be a loaded
question
why is your take on this war so
drastically different than hassan i have
no idea
i can only tell you why i believe what i
believe
i see no serious explanation as to why
putin would not be the aggressor here
um
putin is deciding
that the borders which are supposed to
be respected on the basis of the
okay
it's going to be a big deal here hey
oh back by popular demand um just a few
days after his first engagement with us
uh dilip is here um he is going to give
some brief remarks at the top about the
sanctions announcement today he has a
hard out so he's only going to be able
to take a few questions today but i have
a hard end
which was an hour ago when we started
russia's long previewed invasion of
ukraine has begun and so too has our
response
today the president responded swiftly
and in lockstep with allies and partners
the speed and coordination was historic
in previous sanctions regimes it took
weeks and months to mount a decisive
response
this time we announced our first tranche
of sanctions in less than a day
and in lockstep with allies and partners
in the european union the united kingdom
canada japan and australia right let me
say a few words about the details of the
package
first
is there a baby in there no
there's no easy segue from that
[Laughter]
close your ears
first after consultations overnight with
germany
uh russia's nordstrom 2 natural gas
pipeline will not become operational
canceled it's an 11 billion investment
in a prized gas pipeline controlled by
russia that will now go to waste
and it sacrifices what would have been a
cash cow for russia's coffers
but it's not just about the money
this decision will relieve russia's
geostrategic chokehold over europe
through its supply of gas and it's a
major turning point in the world's
energy independence from russia
second
we've demonstrated the potency of our
financial sanctions and make make no
mistake
this is only the sharp edge of the pain
we can inflict
in lockstep with our allies we're fully
blocking from the global financial
system
the fifth largest russian
uh financial institution veb
this is a glorified piggy bank for the
kremlin that holds more than 50 billion
dollars in assets right we're also fully
blocking prombaya's bank
this is a bank that holds 35 billion
dollars in assets that finances the
activities of the russian military
in plain english
full full block means these banks can no
longer make any transactions with the us
nor with europe as europe matched our
actions
and their assets and our respective
financial systems will be frozen
and let me be totally clear
no russian financial institution is safe
if the invasion proceeds
we are ready to press a button to take
action on the two largest russian
financial institutions which
collectively hold almost 750 billion in
assets or more than half of the total in
the russian banking system
third together with our allies we've
also cut off the russian government the
russian central bank and russian
sovereign wealth funds from new
financing from the u.s and europe the
kremlin can no longer raise money
from the u.s or europe and its new debt
can no longer trade on u.s or european
financial markets
fourth we've fully sanctioned a group of
russian elites and their family members
these individuals share in the corrupt
gains of the kremlin and they will now
share in the pain
other russian elites and their family
members are now on notice that
additional actions could be taken on
them as well
big time i also want to take a minute to
address a key part of the president's
speech on energy markets
we were deliberate to direct the pain of
our sanctions towards the russian
economy not ours
none of our measures are designed to
disrupt the flow of energy to global
markets and we are now executing a plan
in coordination with major oil producers
and major oil consumers to secure the
stability i assume that's a message to
stock traders for tomorrow started this
was the beginning of an invasion and
this is the beginning of our response
the actions we took today were only the
first tranche if putin escalates further
we will escalate further using financial
sanctions and export controls which
we've yet to unveil
but which are fully prepared to
implement with allies and partners
across the world
lastly
make no mistake our response goes well
beyond sanctions and export controls
we're continuing to fortify nato's
eastern flank to reinforce a sacred
article 5 commitment to defend every
inch of nato territory uh just today the
president announced that additional
troops and equipment will be shifted
within europe to the baltics we'll
continue to provide defensive assistance
to ukraine already over the past this is
a proxy war guys we we have to be able
to say that we're not we you don't have
to judge mentally say it but it is a
proxy war assistance to ukraine uh with
the idea being we want to create a
successful alternative in ukraine to
russian russian-style kleptocracy which
may be putin's a war in all ways other
than american troops on the ground
that's that's what it is let's speak a
little bit more about the energy
component and what tools do you have in
the tools given that there's been an
effort ongoing now for several months to
control
the price increases that we're seeing
for uh for gasoline in particular what
can you do to help
energy prices not fight the way that
president biden appears to worry if they
will yeah so this is an ongoing effort
and a sensitive effort i can give you a
bit
a bit of detail on what that involves
number one it involves coordinating
our our actions with major energy
producers we all have reserves at our
disposal and those reserves could help
support the supply of energy worldwide
number two we're working closely with
major energy producers
many of them have several of them have
the spare capacity to provide supply to
global energy markets and to balance the
market in the event of any supply
disruption
number three uh we can work with energy
companies to surge their capacity to
supply energy to the market particularly
as prices rise
and number four we can be very clear
that if president putin weaponizes
energy supply
it will be met with massive consequences
and it will only accelerate the
diversification of europe and the world
away from russian energy can you speak
quickly to the decision to what seems to
be de-linking
the the sanctions initially the
president was signaling if there is an
invasion or a further invasion that the
sanctions would come full stop one swoop
now we're seeing sort of more of a tit
for tat
approach you're warning here today that
president putin goes uh further so will
the sanctions can you walk us through
that process at all it seems like the us
is now breaking its sanctions package
into chunks whereas the expectation had
been that it would come all at once
yeah well look today's today's package
is a severe action i walk through the
elements of it with nordstrom the
financial sanctions sovereign debt and
the elites number two it's just the
beginning this was the beginning of an
invasion this is just the beginning of
our response but number three and this
really gets to your question i think
most fundamentally
no one should think that it's our goal
to max out on sanctions sanctions are
not an end to themselves they serve a
higher purpose
and that purpose is to deter and prevent
they're meant to prevent and deter a
large-scale invasion of ukraine that
could involve the seizure of major
cities including kiev they're meant to
prevent large-scale human suffering that
could involve tens of thousands of
casualties in a conflict and they're
meant to prevent the installation of a
puppet government controlled by moscow
that subjugates the will of ukraine and
prevents the people of ukraine from
choosing their own destiny and setting
their own course that's what this is all
about
what's it going to take to target putin
directly
i'm not going to i'm not going to
telegraph exactly what it would take and
under what circumstances that would
occur but no option is off the table as
the president wow
this is the most dangerous moment in
european security in a generation so if
not today when what
look uh as i say we mounted a very
significant response today we can
escalate that response further there are
a number of actions we can take using
financial sanctions export controls
fortifying our eastern flank uh helping
ukraine defend itself helping each other
deal with the costs and consequences of
russia's invasion and most importantly
having a shared confidence among allies
in our way of life our economic model
our political model if russia wants to
sequester itself from western technology
the western economy
uh and and from western financial
markets that is a bad strategic choice
for russia but we're going to step up in
solidarity to advance our values and
principles
you mentioned that sanctions are meant
to deter and prevent but the fact of the
matter is the sanctions you're
announcing today and that's last night
did not deter or prevent russia's
russia's actions yesterday over the
weekend what gives you any confidence
that the remaining sanctions that
haven't been imposed yet can deter or
prevent a further russian invasion
and aggression in ukraine well look it's
it's it's uh it's day one and
president putin has choices to make we
have choices to make our job our job is
to manage risks and to impose
consequences uh for a further escalation
of this conflict by president putin we
can do that through financial sanctions
we can do that through export controls
we can do that through fortifying nato's
eastern flank we can do that through
providing defensive assistance to
ukraine we can do that by being prepared
for any energy market impact that occurs
from russia's choices those are the
choices that are within our disposal and
let me just take a step back and talk
about sanctions you know we have we have
principles that matter in terms of how
we design
a sanctions package
they need to be
powerful enough to demonstrate our
resolve
and the capacity to impose overwhelming
costs they should be calibrated such
that we can maximize coordination with
our allies and partners
they should maintain flexibility so we
can escalate or de-escalate depending on
what putin does
um they should be responsible it sort of
seems like what what's being said if you
read between the lines is
if we do everything right away and putin
knows that's it
then he knows we can't do any more so it
it seems to be you want to leave
yourself some head room in some sense
you got a question last week so we're
just trying to diversify it a little bit
i just want you to come in simon can you
can you let me ask a question thank you
go ahead
friend of the show weja
i know that you just talked about all
the actions that you're taking to
counter
any oil shortages that might drive up
gas prices but today the president
himself was very blunt about how they
could impact americans so can you just
give us a sense of when americans might
feel
a difference when they fill up their gas
tanks and then secondly
don't do that
zeke was just asking both you and the
president said today that these
sanctions
will be in response um will be if if
putin escalates you will escalate so
that sounds like they are going to be in
response now and not meant to deter so
do you still view them as being
a deterrent or are they just a
punishment at this point
yeah so the first question on energy
markets and the impact of our actions
and when they'll take effect in markets
look
again i i don't want to go into
specifics but there are actions that
energy consumers can take with their
strategic reserves their actions that
energy producers can take in terms of
their spare capacity their actions that
energy producers can undertake to
increase their production of energy in
the current circumstance and uh i'm not
going to give you a timeline but the
collective power of those actions and
all the other tools and authorities that
are at our disposal plus diplomatic uh
diplomatic maneuvers that are at
that are at our disposal collectively we
think uh will be effective in bringing
down uh the price of gas and the price
of oil
[Music]
that's deputy national security advisor
dileep singh and now we will hear from
jenn saki questions from delete we will
have him back and we will make him
available in other capacities as well to
all of you i have one very unrelated but
still very important item for you at the
top and then we'll get back to our
discussion um today in arizona interior
secretary deb holland announced the
interior department's plan to fulfill
settlements of indian water rights
claims using historic funding from
president biden's bipartisan
infrastructure law yeah i do think it's
legitimate to say okay what we've done
is both a punishment for what putin
already did and a signal that if he does
more we will do more like whether it
works or not it's not
absurd that you could say it's both back
from the tribal consul from tribal
consultations the department will
allocate 1.7 billion dollars this year
alone from the infrastructure law to
enact to enacted settlements that have
outstanding federal payments necessary
to complete their terms uh with that
zeke why don't you kick us off and we
will get around to as many people as
possible and i realize it's already late
go ahead thanks jen um
walks to the uh the events the last 24
hours last night a senior administration
official uh a background call with
reporters briefed uh a briefing on the
administrative response and said the
russians occupied these regions since
2014 and that russian troops moving into
the danbots would not end up not of its
uh would not itself be a new step and
didn't use the word invasion this
morning
uh the deputy national security adviser
said invasion the president to see the
invasion
what changed in the last 24 hours what
did you see on the ground that changed
the u.s government's assessment of what
is actually happening
sure well i'm not going to i know this
isn't exactly what you're asking but
just to set the precedent here i'm not
going to be confirming military
movements uh from the podium now or at
any point probably but what i can tell
you is what we looked at is the events
of the last less than 24 hours zeke
right and what we have seen is president
putin
setting up a rationale to take more
territory by force what we're basing
that on including the comments of the
deputy national security adviser this
morning and then the president's
comments later in the afternoon is a
couple of things one vladimir putin
announced yesterday that he was
basically planning to carve out a chunk
of ukraine by recognizing two regions of
ukraine as independent he brazenly
asserted these regions are no longer
part of ukrainian sovereign territory
last night he authorized russian forces
to deploy into these regions today he
sought authorizations authorization from
the duma for the russian military to use
force outside of russian territory and
today he asserted that these regions
actually extend deeper into ukraine
claiming larger areas currently under
jurisdiction of the ukrainian government
so what we're seeing there and as for
anybody who read or paid attention to
his lengthy speech last night is the
rationale to go much further that is
what we are also watching very closely
and this comp for this combination of
reasons we see this as the beginning of
a further invasion of ukraine but we
look at and we assess over the course of
a short period of time
but right now could we say whether or
not the us government believes that
there's been additional deployments of
russian forces active forces across the
border into into ukraine they've been
there for years but additional forces
i'm not going to get into military
assessments of military movements from
here
um a separate topic the president and
really talked about this as well um
warned americans in the last several
weeks that they have to they should be
prepared to bear the cost of standing up
for ukraine's opportunity
there's been a lot of conversation about
this and it's hoping to maybe speak to
clarify this little bit
why should americans uh you know feel
that they have to is that is a cost that
they should have to bear and that should
affect their lives and how much should
they be prepared for this you know
geopolitical crisis to impact their
day-to-day life well i think what
hopefully the american people who are
tuning into this or have been tuning
into this we'll see is that the
president of the united states and in
his entire national security apparatus
have been rallying the world and
standing up against the efforts of
russia to invade and take and carve out
a chunk of another country for their own
um and that is the world is standing
with the united states against the
actions of president putin now why does
that matter i realize that's what you're
asking me why does that matter to the
american people that should matter
because that is a fundamental value that
we as a country stand up
for and we stand up against that type of
action that goes back to world war ii
and and we have repeatedly throughout
history been leaders in the world in
rallying support for any efforts to
seize uh territory from another country
what the when the president spoke to the
american people last week it was very
important to him to be very direct and
clear and straightforward with them
about what this could mean
as we looked to what the impact of an
invasion could mean and also what the
impact of sanctions could mean and the
fact that standing up for values
is not without cost including in this
case including potentially in this
scenario now as to leap just conveyed
what the president has said to his
national security team is he wants to
leave no stone unturned he wants them to
take every step possible to
tap into the resources of global
suppliers
to present to him
any option that will reduce the impact
on the american people and even as he's
looking at sanctions he is taking that
into account but this is about standing
up for american values and making and he
wanted to make clear to them what impact
that could have
thank you jen given what secretary
blinken just announced about his meeting
with um lavrov on thursday is a summit
between the president and putin out of
the question now
well we're never going to completely
close the door to diplomacy and i don't
think the the secretary of state did
that either but just to build on what he
just said uh diplomacy can't succeed
unless russia changes course and as he
said it wouldn't be appropriate for him
to have a meeting
with his counterpart
at this point in time foreign minister
lavrov and it was always intended uh
that any engagement with president putin
would follow that so at this point that
is certainly not in the plans what would
what would it take to get that
conversation back to the table to
reconsider
a meeting between the two leaders well
de-escalation that's what it would take
the escalation means moving troops it
means de-escalating from what the steps
they continue to take on a daily basis
appear to be i'm going to top it quickly
yeah how many supreme court nominees has
the president interviewed by this point
um
that was a wink um i appreciate your
question i understand weija why you're
asking um we are of course a very short
period of time away from the end of the
month of february uh the president has
not made a decision about who he's going
to nominate but i'm not still not going
to get into details six days left
more to tell soon go ahead peter thank
you jen the president said in the spring
that pentagon generals had briefed him
that the greatest threat facing america
is global warming is that still the
assessment now that we are facing down a
potential cyber war with russia
well
let me first say there is no uh well we
are always prepared uh for any threat
that any outside entity or country
opposes the united states relates to
cyber anything else there is no current
pending threat on as it relates to cyber
uh in terms of the threats you're you're
touching on that was a briefing from the
military so i'd point you to them and so
as far as anybody watching who's seen
the coverage it's very at times
distressing images of
russian military movements the
number one threat facing
the country right now remains global
warming well peter i i think it's
important as we're all educating the
public here to convey and reiterate the
president has no intention of sending
u.s troops into ukraine to fight in
ukraine what we are doing is we are
abiding by our obligations to our nato
allies and partners to ensure that they
have the support and the resources uh
that they need and that is our
obligation is the united states okay and
why do you guys think that sanctions are
going to stop putin if his goal
ultimately is to redraw the map so it
looks like it did 70 or 80 years ago
what sanction is going to stop him from
doing that well i i think just to kind
of reiterate maybe something you touched
on there for anyone who watched his
speech last night what he made clear in
that speech is that he doesn't even
necessarily or doesn't recognize the
independence of ukraine as a country and
that certainly gives us an indication of
where his intentions are at this point
in time
sanctions can be a powerful tool they
have been in a lot of
moments throughout history and what we
view them as as or how we're viewing
them as we're starting high as dileep
just conveyed uh here uh in terms of the
significance and the severity of the
sanctions that were announced today
yes our intention is to have it to turn
effect and there are cringes well what
they have done to date is completely
unacceptable there are certainly far
worse that could happen what we want to
do is prevent a large-scale invasion
death and destruction across ukraine
devastation to the ukrainian people and
that what happens with sanctions is they
work overtime they're not an end
they're not intended to max out the
beginning they're long-lasting and
sustainable and they're intended to
squeeze but if you look at what is
happening now what president putin has
stated as as his intention is he wants
to divide nato the opposite of that has
happened peter he also wanted to a
geopolitical project nordstrom 2 to go
forward that has not happened he wants
to make sure there is a a vibrant
economy for the russian people they're
not on that track so his intentions and
his objectives are not playing out so i
guess to follow up on that the president
said before he got here that putin knows
if i am president of the united states
his days of tyranny and trying to
intimidate the united states and those
in eastern europe are over it's two and
a half years later he is intimidating
the united states and those in eastern
europe i'd hardly put it that way i
would look at it actually from the prism
of the united states and president biden
has rallied the world uh rallied europe
uh to stand up against the efforts and
the actions of president putin and we've
laid out very clearly exactly four
dollar gas five dollar gas however how
you guys think it's going to go
something like that remember that the
the gas prices were higher under trump
uh president putin and i think the
evidence of that doesn't exist go ahead
kristen so you know he wants to make it
seem silly to say that global warming is
the greatest threat we face when there
are tanks going from russia into ukraine
any nor this is my segment yesterday
about how
we this entire media space is just
filled with with nuttiness
we can at the same time recognize
if global warming climate change isn't
controlled
famine and natural disasters could kill
hundreds of millions right so you can
hold that in your head long term we got
to control it or famine and all these
things could kill hundreds of millions
and right now
when it comes to militaries
this is an aggressive act by putin a
normal person could understand that but
he wants to go how can you see a tank
and be like global warming's the number
one problem it's a stupid question for
stupid viewers continue to be escalatory
and also if we do all the sanctions now
what is the deterrent effect or impact
of preventing him to take further action
that is what the conversation we've been
in with the global community and that is
how we've been approaching it to date
senator lindsey graham says president
biden is missing a moment does he run
the risk of being too cautious here with
this tranche approach
when what capacity is he missing the
moment did senator ramsey i'll greet you
the important thing if this is a
critical moment in history president
biden is not seizing the moment
someone's got a mic on her did he say
that before after we announced the
sanctions saying this consistently well
look i think it's an important question
because what we what for the president
announced was the sanctioning of two
enormous financial systems this uh
institutions that is essentially going
to make it more difficult for people
close to president putin and in the
russian elite to do business and this is
just the beginning when do you think
they'll start to feel the impact when
will they feel the bite well they're
going to be imp they're going to be
implemented immediately so
obviously it takes some time but but our
effort and our focus is on implementing
them immediately and going back to
president biden's statement that helps
to mitigate the impact on americans
can you tell americans how much pain
will they feel with this first crunch
well i think what we're looking at here
kristin is of course the impact on
natural gas producers primarily is in
europe and we're working to help them
too but also on the oil markets and
obviously there are many additional
steps that president putin could take
and what we're seeing is that he has
every intention of taking so i can't
give you a projection of that some of it
depends on what the actions are the
americans will feel the impact in the
coming weeks of these rounds again it
really depends on what the steps are
what what was announced today was
significant sanctions on russian elite
and on financial institutions there the
people who will be largely impacted are
in russia on those
one more
swift not in this initial vote and then
there's not in the initial tranche but
remains on the table will it be in the
next roll out if there needs to be
another rollout i can't give you a
prediction of that but again uh we have
a range of options that remain on the
table um significant uh
that would have a significant and and uh
and devastating impact on the russian
economy we've already seen in the
russian economy the impact on inflation
there uh and on the markets there of the
expectation of these uh of these uh
sanctions but all of those options
remain on the table and i can't make a
prediction of what's next go ahead the
president today used words like bizarre
and twisted to describe putin's remarks
does the administration believed on what
they saw in this speech yesterday or in
the last 24 hours if you will that putin
has shown some kind of change in his
state of mind and his demeanor seems
unhinged
i wouldn't say we'd characterize it that
way cecilia i mean if you uh for those
of you who read or or watched his speech
last night which was rife with
historical inaccuracy of course uh he
made clear that he
does not view ukraine not just putin was
very strangely rambling and seemed kind
of disconnected from reality he seemed
sort of dazed that by providing a lot of
revisionist history details that are not
aligned with what has happened over the
last few decades now we've seen some of
that rhetoric if you look back back to
2008 and even before then um but it is
indicative of uh you know what of his
own belief that he has the right uh as a
of that russia and he has the right to
take the territory to claim uh territory
from another country and we just don't
agree with that obviously if sanctions
don't work
then what what else is in the tool belt
at the president's disposal at this
point well uh sanctions can take a
number of formats right export controls
is certainly one of them there's many
more sanctions that we have at our
disposal swift the swift system is
obviously significant not in the first
tranche but there's a range of options
that remain on the table for sanctions
and again as to leap conveyed but i
think this is an important component for
to to to know is that they're not
intended to have an impact on the fir
the harshest impact on the first day
they're attempted they're they're
planned or they're um uh they're
designed uh to have a squeezing impact
uh over the course of time and we have
many more escalatory steps that we could
take good do you have specific
agreements with countries exporters to
ensure europe has a steady supply of gas
or is that still a work in progress i i
certainly understand your question as
the leap said it's a very at a very
sensitive time in the process right now
but what we're doing right now is
talking both to major natural gas
producers to understand their capacity
and willingness to surge natural natural
gas output which of course is a regional
issue that would have an impact in
europe and also talking as he said to a
range of uh purdue people in the chat
who has gas electric versus oil for home
heating i'm curious i can't outline any
more details on it from here
the impact that you're on the american
public you mean specifically americans
should expect higher gasoline yeah
energy prices exactly that's that's what
we want the american public to be aware
is a possibility announcing more
oligarchs tomorrow is that the plan
i don't have anything to preview for you
at this point in time but uh i can
certainly check if there's another
trance coming tomorrow absolutely go
ahead and given that the president
stressed today that diplomacy is still
available but now the blinkin lavrov
meeting is off you just said uh this
future a lot more people with electric
heat than i would have guessed now if
you have electric heat do you have
old-school electric baseboards or do you
have new electric heat pumps dealing
with russia
well first uh we still the dorto
diplomacy still remains open um and it
just as i think our foreign our
secretary of state conveyed it isn't the
appropriate time as russia is taking
escalatory steps and preparing to invade
for him to meet with the foreign
minister um and and it had always been
the intention that any engagement with
president putin would be discussed there
and potentially fellow there but there
were never any specific plans or
timeline really in the works for that so
it was really going to be discussed at
that meeting what diplomacy looks like
one we're going to continue to engage
with our european partners of course
and we will continue to
remain open
to
to having diplomatic conversations
once if and when they de-escalate
diplomatic conversation so certainly
between president biden and president
putin
well of course that remains an option
and as we said i think over the course
of the last few days uh he's always
going to be open to having leader to
leader conversations but this isn't the
time to do it when and we said this at
the time as well when they are when
president putin is overseeing the uh
invasion of a of a of a sovereign
country and just quickly um what is the
u.s assessment right now of russian
invasion into keith is that uh
considered an immediate danger right now
yikes it can it is considered i'm not
going to give you a timeline but it can
it's considered a real possibility yes
go ahead thanks uh for weeks jake
sullivan and other club officials have
said that the administration the white
house has learned the lessons of 2014
and you will uh enact
in sanctions you will enact start high
and stay high rather than gradually
escalate
as you talk about the chunks of
different tranches it seems you're doing
the opposite why is that the approach
that you're taking not true actually
we actually didn't sanction these type
of financial institutions back in 2014
and it took several weeks to sanction
these type of institutions but more in
terms of the theory of the case that
instead of doing it in pieces where you
start and then continue to add on the
lessons that jake and others have
signaled was that you start high and
stay high
instead of doing it more peacefully well
that's exactly what we're doing so the
announcement that was made today about
these financial institutions is more
significant that was than what was done
in 2014 and we would only build further
from here so that is starting high and
staying high
go ahead
what russian actions would trigger the
fullest extent of u.s sanctions man it's
a lot of the same question over and over
again it really is
obviously we have a range of options at
our disposal
they're all remain on the table and i
would love for someone to say is the
administration comfortable with the
reality that we are here fighting a war
in all but name only with everything
other than drones and boots on the
ground we're doing everything else it's
essentially a proxy war
i i can't go into specific more
specifics just a range of options around
the table and obviously export control
actions would have a significant uh
additional impact uh on the economy uh
there uh in terms of tell me your first
part of your question again oh yeah just
is the administration confident that
sanctions and export controls can deter
putin
part of what sanctions are is they have
they're they're intended to be a
deterrent but they are also intended to
have a squeezing uh significant impact
on the economy that is felt over a
sustainable period of time that makes it
more difficult to continue those
behaviors and those actions
they're not they're not intended or
designed to
to be an end when they're initially
announced
so that those are the range of options
we have at our disposal and there will
continue to be a growing impact go ahead
uh thanks the president said last week
that he was hoping to maybe work with
congress on some sort of proposal to
address energy prices is that still on
the table or is this focus now on sort
of diplomacy with producers and
consumers all is on the table and what
might that look like uh discussions with
congress yeah would it be the form of
legislation to lower prices i mean what
kind of policies that is an option but i
don't have anything to detail for you at
this point in time another subject the
u.s and several countries are close to
reaching a nuclear deal with iran
um what's the likelihood of an agreement
you know this week in your view and
would the u.s agree to a deal that does
not include the release of u.s and
british prisoners held by iran
well let me let me start with your
second uh question because this isn't a
really important one but the discussions
on unjustly detained and innocent
americans remain separate from the jcpoa
talks a special
envoy mali has reiterated it's very hard
for us to imagine getting back into the
nuclear deal or agreeing to kind of a
new iteration of the deal to the point
of your question while four innocent
americans and others are being held
hostage
by iran it's really a matter of urgency
to bring the detainees home we want it
to be resolved immediately but is
happening from a through a separate
channel those conversations in terms of
the status of the jcpoa talks we have
made substantial progress or substantial
progress has been made over the last
week or so and is continuing to be a
maid
nothing is agreed until everything is
agreed and so until then i'm not going
to give you a rosy assessment
but it is of course good that
substantial progress has been made
if ron shows seriousness we believe we
can and should reach an understanding
and mutual return to full implementation
of the jcpoa
is the president concerned at all about
the convoy of truckers that's making its
way to washington and is he taking any
sort of steps to protect
yes we've actually been
been monitoring uh this closely the
department of homeland security and the
administration are tracking reports of a
potential convoy that may be planning to
travel to several u.s cities including
washington d.c
we have been working including from dr
lisherwood randle here as well as our
homeland security department with
closely with our federal state and local
partners to continuously assess the
threat environment keep our communities
safe
and our efforts uh include enhanced
intelligence sharing a critical incident
response plan for the u.s capital a
regional security assessment and a
simulation experiment that developed
data-driven recommendations to bolster
regional security so we are closely
monitoring closely watching and working
with state and local authorities uh let
me go ahead great first just want to
thank everybody i know it's late who's
um we're eliminating our questions so
that more people can yes sure so i
appreciate that and if anybody needs to
go for a hit or anything nobody will
take it personally i know some people
have go ahead so um one question of
course um on ukraine first of all delete
said just now that today's sanction
package is quote just the beginning of
it
does that mean if nothing changes you
expect more sanctions or what does that
mean just the beginning of it it means
we have a range of additional options
that we have the ability to take and if
president putin continues to escalate so
will we
look into the state of the union
when was the last time president biden
spoke to a member of congress about any
item in the build bank better agenda he
has a range of conversations all the
time but i'm not going to detail the
timeline of those for you
go ahead
when can we expect a more detailed
explanation from the white house about
how it would plan to bring down energy
prices
well i think as the leap just conveyed a
lot of what's happening right now is
sensitive it includes uh conversations
with foreign better answer would be the
white house can do very little about
energy prices continuing to have with
congress and others about
what steps may be at our disposal and
the president is continuing to consider
options so i expect we'll have more to
tell you when any decisions are made and
given what we have heard publicly from
the russians in the last several days
what level of concern does the white
house have that the conflict could spill
over out of ukraine and into some of the
other nations that the u.s has vowed to
protect militarily and are part of nato
well without making any prediction of
that what i can tell you is that one of
the steps we've taken including an
announcement that the department of
defense made today about uh plussing up
of an additional 800 personnel to the
baltic region from italy is that we take
our uh our commitments to our nato
allies and partners seriously and we are
going to continue to take steps to plus
up their support uh and ensure that they
know that they have the backing of the
united states but i'm not going to make
any other predictions of that go ahead
thanks a lot um
that was a little scary go ahead
all right
yes i just wanted to ask what concrete
assurances were they able to secure on
on managing potential market pressures
uh from saudi arabia i certainly
understand the question we did confirm
that they went on a trip and they
discussed a range of issues including
yemen uh but also including uh steps to
take to steps we can all take to
coordinate and reduce the impact on the
global market on oil
of oil
but i can't detail anything further from
here if one of the objectives is not to
disrupt global energy flows and energy
prices are high and rising
how how can russia's bottom line really
be hurt if you don't disrupt
global energy flows
well i think russia's bottom line can be
hurt in a lot of ways including the
range of sanctions we've already
announced today and additional sets of
sanctions that we have at our disposal
should they choose whether it's
sanctioning additional individuals or
taking okay there's more and more people
in the chat who seem to be aware that
there is one article that i am aware of
that claims queen elizabeth has died it
is being refuted
uh and at this time
it is one article
and it's being refuted that she is dead
so that that's uh
i you know i don't that's all i know all
assessing uh what steps we can take that
will have a crippling impact on them
while reducing the impact on the
american public
go ahead thanks jen i'm just trying to
get a better idea of what the
administration deems to be an escalation
on the part of russia again it is being
denied it is one article from
a website i'm unfamiliar with making the
claim it has not been announced in any
formal way and it is being refuted areas
of ukraine or would it be the continued
deployment of forces i'm not reporting
that the queen is dead i'm reporting
that the rumor is being denied as of
right now
as you have seen hopefully as russia has
taken any escalatory steps we have taken
escalatory
steps on our end in the form of
sanctions and so i'm not going to
outline for you if this then then but i
think if for those of you again who
watched the speech last night the
president president putin direct
attacked ukraine's
right to exist he's explicitly
threatened war unless
his extreme demands were met he gave an
entire speech selling a war to the
russian people our expectation and we
hope we are wrong is that he will
continue to take escalatory actions and
further invade the country and we will
take additional steps in response
is the administration preparing any sort
of measures for ukrainians already in
the united states such as tps or any
other sort of immigration protections
for those who might not want to go back
sure i don't obviously those decisions
or assessments are made by the
department of homeland security i can't
make a prediction of that at this point
in time obviously what we are doing on
the ground is trying to provide a range
of economic humanitarian and security
assistance to the ukrainian government i
understand you're asking about people
who are here and obviously we are
preparing for
the potential for
major humanitarian outflows that could
go into europe and have a range of needs
and so that is also something we are
closely tracking we are also poised to
increase our support to the people of
ukraine should additional humanitarian
needs arise our response would be based
on assessment of the needs our partners
emergency appeals in coordination with
our european allies and partners but we
are assessing the humanitarian assist
situation on the ground
very closely and we're going to continue
to engage with allies and partners about
any humanitarian needs that escalate and
refugee outflows uh if they are to
continue to occur we're getting close to
the deadline i'm just are scottish
interviews done at this point i know
it's all in process i know but you know
are they done at this point we already
didn't answer that process will soon be
over so that's the good news um i'm not
going to detail the status but i can
tell you that the president has not made
a decision yet but we remain on track
for him to make a decision and make an
announcement before the end of the month
go ahead you
um i know you said you didn't like
military questions too much but no i
love military questions i'm just not
going to outline military movements from
here okay fine um because
one uh one um one kind of salient
aspect this whole thing has been
actually the openness of the us in
giving military details about what the
russians are up to so i'm wondering if
you can go a little further with that um
it seems important that people don't
really understand like
these you know the so-called
peacekeepers like how many are there are
they in donbass now is it a handful of
people is it a few guys with like you
know jeeps or is it tons of tanks
missiles but
i i don't think americans really have a
good idea of what
it is what this invasion actually
consists of sure and i appreciate it
and another question
would be um
uh there's obviously no us trainers in
ukraine anymore
um will this training military training
relationship continue in a third country
sure on the second i would point you to
the department of defense who's best
equipped to answer that question um on
the first it's a really important one uh
you know i think it's important for the
american public who may be just tuning
in to know that there have been a
military russian military presence in
ukraine uh since back to 2014 which they
never admitted they never acknowledged
in some ways they've only recently
acknowledged back in 2014 and in the
years after we called them the little
green men because they were not in
russian military uniform now we know
that they are all over uh eastern
ukraine um and they are uh well not in
uniform they are behaving just like
russian military would be behaving um so
that is something i can't give you a
number or specifics from here because i
can't get into intelligence but it is
important for the american people to
know that that that regardless of
whether they're in uniform or not they
have been there since 2014 they are
representing the russian government they
are separatists who are we probably
should stop calling them peacekeepers
because they are certainly not that uh
who are uh you know helping to um lay
the predicate for war and that is what
the purpose of a lot of them is
change in the last therefore hours i
think that's that's really the question
yes i'm not gonna i'm not going to be
able to give you any additional
assessment of that at this point in time
from here
but i understand your question will
continue to work to give you more go
ahead thanks john two quick questions on
nordstrom two um the first is the deputy
director just said that stopping
nordstrom ii
relieved europe of a geostrategic
chokehold that russia would have had on
them so
if nordstrom 2 going online was such a
threat why in may did the president wave
sanctions on the company and the chief
executive behind it and my second
question is
um
is there
a concern
that nordstrom 2 if russia were to make
concessions or
uh retreat in some way that that might
open up the door to nordstrom 2 going
back online or is it your understanding
that it is dead no matter what russia
does
well i would first say that um you know
the president has never been a supporter
of nordstrom 2. we've always
criticized it as a as a a project that
we didn't support we took a range of
steps and sanctions including sanctions
to make that very clear
what the announcement made by the german
chancellor today was
not by accident it was at the conclusion
of a range of diplomatic engagement and
efforts by the president and members of
our national security team and unity
from their europeans about the fact that
this could not move forward we've never
felt the president didn't feel that
issuing pre-emptive sanctions on that
was the right step to take
but look where we are nordstrom 2 is not
moving forward and by the way it hasn't
been operational anyway so you know
that's a fact that's not moving forward
at this point in time in terms of the
future we've never felt it was a good
project we've been clear about that and
that assessment i don't expect would
change in the future go ahead thank you
jen does the white house any have any
reaction to former president trump
calling putin's move yesterday genius
and smart yes well as a matter of policy
there you go we try not to take advice
from anyone who
praises president putin and his military
strategy which i believe is what
happened there expresses an openness to
lifting sanctions about the seizing of
territory in crimea uh or at any point
in time told leaders of the g7
that crimea is a part of russia
regardless if they are a former
president so uh there's a bit of a
different tactic a bit of a different
approach and that's probably why
president biden and not his predecessor
was able to rally the world and the
global community in taking steps against
uh against russia's aggression is there
any fear that statements like that could
turn support for ukraine into a more
partisan issue among the u.s public
by the former president
you know i think that is up to members
of the republican party to make the
decision to make the determination um
it has there has a long history decades
of history which president biden was a
part of when he was chairman of the
foreign relations committee of standing
up to the efforts of any country to
seize the territory
of another country standing up for
efforts by the united states to rally
global support
against
against inappropriate
and illegal actions by another country
there's a long history of that not a
partisan way trump's calling it a
perfect invasion choice is up to
republicans to make to determine go
ahead thank you jen i've got two
questions quickly um the administration
rolled out a list of sanctions against
russian oligarchs and elites
my question is are any of them being
sanctioned for the first time or are
these sort of repeat bad funders
that's a good question i'm sure we can
get you a breakdown of that i believe
some of them are new um and certainly
the banks are new but let us get you a
more specific breakdown of that my
second question is the last time jake
sullivan was here he said that a russian
invasion of ukraine would lead to u.s
sanctions warning that that wouldn't
necessarily make moscow more beholden
to beijing obviously both of those
foreign powers aren't exactly the most
friendly to us so is the administration
taking any steps
or issuing any warnings to keep those
geopolitical foes from
you know aligning together and marching
at blackstone well long before uh the
events of the last few months we saw
china and russia moving closer together
in some capacity but right now as we're
looking at the actions of president
putin and the uh as we're preparing for
him to further invade uh ukraine to uh
to uh unfortunately put forward death
and destruction on the country and the
people of ukraine it's really a question
for china on whether they look at that
and think that's acceptable behavior so
i think you saw that our secretary of
state had a conversation with his
counterpart in the last 24 or 48 hours
and we will certainly remain and
continue to engage but i think it's
about looking at where the global
community is in this moment and
determining where you want to stand
uh okay go ahead thanks jen i wanted to
ask um about rapid covent tests do you
have an update at this point on how many
you've shipped and how many of under
contract
i believe we do uh but i'm gonna have to
get that to you after the briefing um we
have uh let me get that to you after the
briefing because i think we have some
updated numbers on that i think we're
gonna have to wrap up shortly here go
ahead in the back thank you thank you i
uh i'm sorry i have to step out let's go
for a live uh shot for a moment but so
if somebody asked this question i'm
sorry
but i would like to clarify what dalip
said
at the beginning he said that
not film 2
will go
to waste now
so do you have assurance from germany
that
it's the decision to cancel the project
is final or it's still reversible
well i i would really i don't have
anything to build on beyond what uh the
strong statements and the strong
comments of uh the chancellor uh this
morning uh and the president's own
statements about how it would not move
forward okay thanks everyone we'll see
you tomorrow
so there is the press briefing from jen
saki we will see what the latest is over
on cnn
a number of different questions and
ideas and different things coming in
from different people uh we
it is completely plausible that um putin
won't do anything else for a couple of
weeks uh to let the heat die down and
then sort of do the next thing we we
really just don't know at this time what
he has planned things calm
in maidan square in kiev we are
monitoring uh the the latest there's a
very interesting a lot reddit live
where you can uh continue to see
what is being said and different
elements that are being included there
but a lot of different things going on
and a lot of different things to track i
want to say thank you to donnell bullock
who just signed up on my website using
the coupon code
please don't war and on that basis
because we are at 49
whoever is number 50
you get a free item from my online store
we've got hoodies we've got t-shirts
hats coffee mugs tea mugs water mugs
juice mugs
it's really all the same mug i guess
just you can put whatever you want
didn't it um whoever is number 50 at
joinpakman.com we are at 49. you will
get a free item from the store shipped
anywhere in the world where we can
deliver we probably can't get it to
north korea there's probably some remote
areas of the world we can't get it to
but uh we will we will do our absolute
best to get it to you
absolutely wherever you are which is
very very important avr drum says is it
time to start asking and renewing
discussions on buildback better
buildback better is feeling very dead
very very dead but obviously i would
love to see that reverse
uh but it's not clear to me
uh that that is going to happen
many streams this hold on let's see
what's going on here
more us forces and military equipment
into key positions in europe as he
confirms that russia is beginning an
invasion of ukraine uh we're joined now
by cnn military analyst retired major
general james spider-marx oh no not
march walk us walk our viewers through
the region right now uh that's
considered the front lines where putin
is ordering russian troops to move in
when they pull out general marks when
they pull out spider marks and put up
these maps
you know someone's clamoring for war
that's for damn sure um and uh let's
take it all in
this is the donbass region now
specifically what was just annexed
officially in putin's eyes is this area
right here and this is the line of
separation that has been in place for
close to eight years that line was on
the map has had forces in this area
for eight years supporting the
separatists as they try to separate from
kiev what's most important however and
what we're talking about now is what
happens in the greater donbas is putin
ready to move forward now we have some
video that shows the movement of forces
logistics self-propelled artillery
infantry fighting vehicles and all these
videos i don't think i want to do the
military porn stuff right now i do want
to say thanks to crispin driver
schroeder who is new member number 50
today crispin you get a free item from
my online store please email info at
davidpakman.com to claim it also want to
say thanks to joshua bubus and edward
stewart for signing up on my website
numbers 51 and 52. all right everybody
that's going to do it for me we heard
from blinken
we heard from saki we heard from biden
we heard from everybody
i guess there's a war
and it's not looking great right now
we will be back i'm sure tomorrow
thursday cpac starts we'll be streaming
thursday friday saturday sunday tuesday
we will then have biden state of the
union
um it is a lot a lot a lot a lot is
going on
but we will be back and appreciate
everybody joining me